So the current state of gene patenting, thanks to the decision on
June 2013, I think it was June 13th 2013, on the Myriad
case is that human genetic
code is not patentable. However, code that
is synthesized. From, like if you, I cannot
say, I patent that mutation you have because I discovered it.
However, if you synthesize that DNA, think it's called cDNA.
>> Mm-hm. That is patentable. Because that is
a product of human innovation. So a lot
of the debate over the Myriad case and
the patenting of genes has really been about
the purpose of patents in the United
States. And, you know, this whole history of
intellectual protection in the United States which is
super fun stuff that probably doesn't need to
be done in depth in a genetics course. But the purpose of the patent code is to
protect the fruits of human innovation. Yet if you have worked on something and
you have created something, you are entitled to
control it and profit off of that for a,
you know, protected period of time which has
changed, of course, throughout patent protection history. But you're
entitled to exclusively profit off of that for
a period of time as a reward for your
labor in bringing this new thing into the
world. So patenting of natural materials, has actually been.
There's a pretty extensive case law. That this was not something that
you could do. Because you can't just you know, discover a mold. Scoop it out and
say, I patent this. I get to use this mold alone. A lot of
people were arguing that genes, the discovery
of a genetic mutation, took so much effort and took so much ingenuity to
isolate and to interpret this information, that that made it patentable.
And there actual you know, Myriad's patents were not the first to be issued.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Myriad isr eally just the
worst behaved patenter of human genetic information.
>> They didn't make any friends.
>> Exactly.
>> And even since the Supreme Court
decision it seems that they're still going after people. I know that there
are companies that You know we're trying to run with the supreme court decision.
>> Mm-hmm.
>> And Myriad is still suing them.
>> Yes. Yeah there's plenty of cleanup work left to be done.
>>
[LAUGH]
>> but yea, over the course of this litigation a lot
of people were arguing. Instead of invalidating patents like this. Or
instead of having this compulsory licensing system. Was another idea that
is, it's, you know, common to further scientific innovation by licensing.
>> Mm hmm.
>> Your patent, licensing your discovery. And
the whole problem with Myriad's holding of
these patents that led to all these lawsuits is they didn't grant any licenses,
which was putting a choke hold on
research. And of course an individual's ability
to access a diagnostic test to determine
whether or not they had these mutations.